good morning this is our last day in
Hawaii and it's raining like crazy
there's no sunshine we're gonna make the
best out of it and I think we're going
to the beach thing matter sunburn that's
right what the hell is Bart doing oh we
missed it
so Bart was just running on the road for
no reason that was weird
it's crazy wait lover what is he doing
it was enough yeah today's a different
kind of light it was pouring all morning
I got woken up by the rain and there's
like flash flood warning
hopefully we're still able to swim
so Tony are you eating a Barbie - looks
good
a jealous over your pancakes right now
that's really good
this has got to be the best brave you've
ever had a loco moco very tasty say the
beef patty was kind of talk a little
overcooked in my opinion we are at a
fruit stand in Hawaii
stripper money Wow giving nothing but
one she's trying to make it rain
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh I got some the
hangman go pickled mango that's one of
my favorite Hawaiian desserts are you
getting really good I'm filming for our
our family bugs in the renu-it how you
were talking to him answer Nibiru day oh
yeah what do you think of the star fruit
stop it was good it's like an apple and
a great mix together but jesse is a
pickled mango that I bought at the fruit
stand Hawaiian style li hing powder with
some vinegar and some mango nice and
sour and sugary now we're at Sunset
Beach and look how beautifully calm this
ocean is look at that this Beach is so
cool
do you prefer a sunny day at the beach
or a gloomy day at the beach this is
perfect
no no sunburns right yeah no sunburns
that's the sunscreen it probably still
should but I'm not going to put
sunscreen in Hakone what's your favorite
thing here have an explorer caption but
lazy well as pouring rice for myself and
I would pour it in the only ones ahead
big hair in it right there that means
you're lucky the Chan Man culture apart
so hard I didn't know I was gonna say so
far I know I how did you feel - I guess
reveal your Anissa t-bills um number one
very liberating it's not black be quiet
now amongst my friends I can share
things about myself
wanting to share but it's so crazy
because for the last six or seven years
that I've been keeping a secret I still
have a lot of natural tendencies so for
example like I was hanging out by the
hole with everyone also hanging out and
I get this phone call and I see that
it's my mom calling me as soon as I see
her I immediately look for a place to go
talk on the phone and then I realized oh
[ __ ] everyone knows oh then I pick it up
cause they want to speak Chinese on the
phone and it's crazy I'm so engrained in
me too so secretive about it I still
have like these subconscious Tennessee
doctor do you find it polished for you
to have done what you did and terms of
hiding your background or do you think
they still stand behind what you did
I don't reason why I and my ethnicity
he found one of its goals was to unite
all Asian Americans and given at that
time a lot of Asian American talent
we're very segregated like the [ __ ] a
pop star became being supporting them
when Jeremy Lin got big only training
people support Jeremy Lin so it was a
huge role for jgomes - you're not always
because we felt like I was a holy way
the only way we can get asian-american
content over but in today's ecosystem I
feel like accomplished that with JK news
now we have
where now all these JK news lovers in
the world
it wasn't even go past the call that we
wanted achieve good night all nation so
now's the time I can come out because
now our content is so strong so
relatable
straight so I don't think it's foolish
that I think it was a necessary thing
that we have to do and it was necessary
to take separate years to see all just
surprised me with the present is she so
sweet and I had to chase her to give her
a hug she didn't want to accept my hug
we need to go ambush her with a hug I
know she wouldn't has to run and get her
Hawaii is kind because we're leaving the
other train Hawaii that would leave
don't go I don't
what if
you have to come visit us like you care
ASAP come okay go now let's go yes
all right you just poured it
sitting away to carry out
hey by Hawaii we're gonna miss you so be
back soon hopefully only have to read
that affair but it says Allah
I don't think about it